grace I got you thinner warmest dossier
I'm sorry it's just it it took me hours
to put her to hell
okay what's wrong
[Music]
we interview ladies yourself about the
upcoming movie the most expensive in
cinematic history London capture of
terror filling we will that's director
Lady Elaine the most pressing question
of all who will play terror villain can
any actor to channel the pure evil of
one of history's greatest mass murderer
the helm five minutes my brothers and
sisters for the longest time I've been
hearing through the grapevine about this
resistance leader important I I'm so
sorry I'm still trying to calibrate the
[ __ ] mmm-hmm Horton
Courtney nurse who will hold up in the
New Orleans ghetto now this man has
important connections to the remaining
fragments of the resistance all over the
US so blaskowitz I need you to go in
there and recruit this man - all calls
you did however this [ __ ] ain't gonna be
easy
Nazis got this great [ __ ] wall
all around New Orleans heavily armed
guard towers and the coast line is
riddled with mines impossible for the
u-boat to navigate but you know what
[ __ ] them anyway because we got
something else I'm sorry
furgus will break into the east
perimeter security tower located there
in Lake Borgne and deactivate the mines
obstructing the channel to Lake
Pontchartrain then we sail this boat
into the sea
all hiding souls on board
as you can see we have new Wolfenstein 2
the new Colossus gameplay Bethesda
revealed that BJ blaskowitz will have a
number of contraptions at his disposal
like a constrictor to access tight
spaces stilts for vertical mobility and
the power to break through walls in
doors this new footage not only
showcases these three enhancements but
also reveals how easy it is to burn
Nazis while riding on the back of a
Panzer hoon so what new feature has you
excited let us know in the comments
below and you can count on us having a
review of Wolfenstein 2 when it drops on
October the 27th thanks for watching
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the Big Easy can't undo your tragedy but
I can punish the people responsible
[Music]
looks like I got a shortcut through this
building
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't get across to the other side then
yet I can make use of that overhead tray
alright cry up and running
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it sounds like someone is putting up a
fight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
take my
you appreciate know this Oh lower pick
these rags up off the streets
names [ __ ] lien J blaskowitz last Terra
Bella Hellfire Sun ain't you supposed to
be dead I recovered well Tara bill II
don't mean to be rude but what's your
business around these parts apart from
saving our sorry asses
I'm with the kreisau circle we're
starting a revolution are you now this
here's the last remaining haven for the
cancer is broken free think it's written
all over the south and Jana won't we be
the outcast the pool
well everyone away partying all the time
the frame parish Jack Paris Jack is a
rock cutter
true believe an anarchist hell of a
clarinet player in that rap parents
don't like the two Longhorns it
literally streets are quiet Gordon
nobody wait yes streets are quiet
that's the professor she got there my
eyes can see a speck of dirt the cow's
ass off a hundred yards I'll tell you
they've got them nasty something just
coming here we gonna shoot their asses
that I'll tell you what come on hot in
the plays glory hallelujah you got a lot
of good people here you should join us
we could always use more good people how
you reckon start this revolution of
yours terror villain terribilis kind of
told safety to go [ __ ] yourself
he's with the kreisau circle walking
this
damnit here they come Paris I'm feeling
a little jittery you mind taking the
edge off let me see what I can do
never trust a man cold Hortense fish
now listen Tara belly I respect your
ambition but there's nothing gonna be
done no more the world sank into the
crab burn all we can do now is drink
this whiskey who wants to pour sake suck
it over there didn't expect your belly
to be quite strong yeah we've been
fighting for revolution since long
before the Nazis came we were the first
start build a civil rights movement that
advocated quality for everyone you know
the concept of civil rights Tara belly
no you don't use the jarhead
I laid my life on the line for freedom
justice the American Way while you and
your bohemian friends were passing out
Bolshevik propaganda and opposing the
draft on every street corner
what good is your [ __ ] equality you
can muster the backbone to stick up for
your people
while the Coyotes scratching at your
[Music]
foreign lands so that they can be
filling their coffers it works their
songs bleeding on the beaches slowly
Trek deep lucky for the dirty work while
they's watching the dollars roll in you
the palm the patty of takers man of
marble mix but I sleep too next [ __ ]
decided not to be a party to it yeah
here you are guns in hand shooting Nazis
just like me differences you come late
to the party
[Music]
belly
[Applause]
this is how I got time for your
horseshit you got to make the call
give up and dive step the [ __ ] up
I've got kids on the way and I'll be
damned if I'm gonna raise them in a
world run by these Nazi [ __ ] so
what's it gonna be your hillbilly
degenerate moonshiner Bolshevik towers
goddamn traitor
[Music]
hello you never seen a man oh man
coherent after more than one shot oh
we're holding special I like you like
here goes
most revelation month now
yeah
he's quick learner parents over sit down
yes sir you're gonna ride on that
they're off and that's it fire well we
make our way down to the harbour with
all those who survived the curse that's
all angels on that pony here is showing
up
[Music]
that's Norman in like flies on a ship
all sector Billy let's see what this
puppy can do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you